aujourd'hui dans la plus éprouvante des
étapes pyrénéennes
lance armstrong s'est offert une très
sérieuse option sur une troisième
victoire consécutive dans le tour de
france l'américain désormais en jaune
l'a emporté au pla d'adet avec une
facilité toujours aussi déconcertante
une étape marquée par de nombreuses
chutes mais surtout une formidable
échappée en solitaire de laurent
jalabert 194km d'anthologie résumé par
nathanaël de rincquesen et alain poirier
sur la ligne de saint lary laurent
jalabert était bien le coureur le plus
attendu emporté dans la foule
le français a encore vécu une sacrée
journée 170 km d'échappée seul face au
peloton
dans une étape aux allures de montagnes
russes alors jalabert joue les
équilibristes dans les vertigineuse
descente pyrénéenne à près de 80 km
heure pas le temps de reprendre son
souffle
voilà déjà la route qui s'élève une
nouvelle difficulté sur le terrain des
grimpeurs jalabert n'est pas là pour
faire de la figuration
il enchaîne l'école et les attentions
plus dur les unes que les autres à 50
kilomètres de l'arrivée le français à
dix minutes d'avancé sur armstrong
derrière jalabert la bagarre éclate
jan ullrich tente le tout pour le tout
mais n'arrive pas à décrocher armstrong
l'allemand prend des risques un peu trop
dans la descente de peyresourde
il rate un virage
plus de peur que de mal oulrich remonte
en selle prêt à se lancer aux trousses
de l'américain inutile armstrong
l'attend quelques kilomètres plus bas
oui ça c'est pas continuer à attaquer
quand un champion
toujours en tête de la course jalabert
est à son tour victime d'une chute au
pied de la dernière ascension mais le
français repart quelques mètres plus
tard sous vélo lui joue des tours
encore des secondes de perdues à 10 km
de l'arrivée
comme pour lui ôter tout regret
armstrong dans les derniers lacets de la
montée vers saint lary démarre comme
d'habitude au nez et à la barbe d'une
riche jalabert est vite rejoint cette
fois il n'y a plus personne
sur le chemin de l'américain qui s'en va
remporter sa troisième victoire du tour
et enfilé son premier maillot jaune de
l'année certainement pas le dernier non